- [Announcer] Principles for Success.
An ultra mini-series
adventure in 30 minutes
and in eight episodes.
Episode Two, Embrace
Reality and Deal With It.
- The path you take in life is
your most important decision.
In my case, I wanted my life to be great
and I feared boredom and mediocrity
more than I feared failure.
Since I didn't start out with money,
and I didn't need much
more than a bed to sleep in
and food to eat, I could skew my decisions
to pursue my adventures.
So ever since I was a kid,
I ran after the things
I wanted, crashed, got up and ran again,
and crashed again.
And each time I crashed I
learned something, got better,
and crashed less.
By doing that over and over again,
I learned to love this process,
even the crashing part of it.
Through it, I encountered reality,
and I learned how to deal with it,
which inspired another one of
my most fundamental principles
which is that truth is
the essential foundation
for producing good outcomes.
By truth, I don't mean anything more than
the way the world works.
I believe that we were given
the laws of reality by nature.
Humans didn't create
them, but we can use them
to foster our own evolution
and achieve our goals.
Realizing that made me a hyperrealist,
by which I mean I became
someone who has discovered
the great rewards of deeply
understanding, accepting,
and working with reality as it is
and not as I wish it would be.
When I say I'm a hyperrealist,
people sometimes think
I'm saying that dreams can't come true.
That's absolutely not true.
Without pursuing dreams, life is mundane.
What I mean is that to me,
hyperrealism is the best way
to choose one's dreams
and then achieve them.
Having big dreams plus
embracing reality plus having
lots of determination will
bring you a successful life.
I believe this formula
is true for everyone,
but what does a successful life look like?
We each have to decide for
ourselves what success is.
I don't care whether you want
to be a master of the universe
or to live under a palm
tree or anything else.
I really don't.
Each of us chooses goals based
on our values and decides
on the best path to achieve
them, but we all need approaches
to making decisions that work
well, especially when facing
problems, mistakes, and
weaknesses that stand in our way.
To succeed, we must
embrace all our realities,
especially the harsh realities
that we wish weren't true.
At first, looking at these
harsh realities caused me
a lot of pain, but I learned
that this pain was just
psychological and that by
seeing things differently made
all the difference.
I came to view problems like
puzzles that would reward me
if I could solve them.
They would help me deal
with the problem at hand,
and they would give me
principles for dealing
with similar problems in the future.
I learned to treat pain as
a cue that a great learning
opportunity is at hand,
which led me to realize
that pain plus reflection equals progress.
Meditation has been invaluable
in helping me see things that way.
I found that when I calmed myself down
and embraced my realities
and dealt with them,
the rewards brought me
pleasure and the pain faded.
Each of us has the unique
capability to think logically
to reflect on ourselves
and our circumstances
and to direct our own personal evolution.
Doing this well is just
a matter of following
a simple five-step process.
In episode three, we'll
explore what that process is
and how to use it.
(words whooshing)